à chaque jour son nouveau concept est
celui ci risque de faire du bruit
marlène schiappa connu pour son franc
parler a une fois de plus fait le buzz
autour d'un concept pour le moins clair
créer des quartiers sans relou ne soyez
pas en imaginant que vous allez pouvoir
vous débarrasser de votre voisin relou
qui fait du bruit et qui ne dit pas
bonjour en descendant les poubelles le
sujet est bel et bien clair cibler les
harceleurs de rue et faire cesser ces
pratiques
laissez nous tranquilles nous vous
siffle pas dans la rue donc soyez
respectueux et respecté allen japa
aujourd'hui ministre délégué chargé de
la citoyenneté a décidé de lancer à
partir de cette année un baromètre
annuel sur le harcèlement de rue tenter
d'endiguer le phénomène initiatives
qu'elle a résumé au journal 20 minutes
ce que l'on veut c'est créer des qsr des
quartiers sans relou alors harcèlement
est ce utile de mettre en place des
quartiers sont relou parler de chapa est
avec nous ce soir pour nous parler de ce
projet
[Musique]
merci à valencia pas d'être avec nous
merci à jean bessis alors marlène
schiappa merci ils ont également alors
marlène schiappa aujourd'hui tout le
monde n'a parlé que de vous c'est vrai
qu'on est franchement vous êtes très
forte parce que l'appellation quartier
son rôle ou c2c de vous c'est à fait non
c'est fort parce qu'au gouvernement
nommé de rien c'est non mais c'est en
tout cas tout le monde en a parlé
moi ce matin au bureau tout le monde m'a
dit est ce que vous vous étiez à vue
mais le nouveau truc de marlène des
quartiers sans relou alors expliquez
vous savez de quoi les quartiers sans
doute mais l'idée en fait c'est de faire
parler un peu la question du harcèlement
de rue et surtout de lutter concrètement
vous savez qu'on a fait voter une loi en
2018 pour verbaliser le harcèlement de
rue et puis il ya eu 3023 verbalisation
de harcèlement de rue exactement c'est
beaucoup parce qu'à l'époque on disait
qu'on n'arriverait pas à verbaliser mais
c'est pas encore assez on sait qu'en
fait c'est à beaucoup plus de phénomènes
de harcèlement de rue que ça donc l'idée
pour nous c'est vraiment d'avoir un
mapping un baromètre du harcèlement de
rue et de déployer des patrouilles de
policiers notamment en civil pour qu'il
puisse agir sur du flagrant délit est
confiée c'est mieux entraver le
harcèlement de rues des quartiers sont
relou donc 100 personnes qui ont un
regard fixe sont insistants des gestes
inappropriés non désirées pression
d'accepter un rendez vous de donner son
numéro de téléphone ou toutes autres
informations personnelles sifflement
bruit avec l'élève bruits d'animaux
commentaires blague à connotation
sexuelle sur leur corps humiliation
publique insultes se faire appeler
poupée bébé voilà les harcèlements de
rue les plus répond il répondu un voile
alors est-ce qu'on pourrait que c'est
une bonne idée
la part de marlène schiappa ou des
tweets gilles verdez absolument dans la
rue dans les transports vous aujourd'hui
des tas de femmes vivent l'enfer c'est
plus possible alors on dit et ce qu'il
faut appeler ça son rouleau moi je
trouve ça très bien on peut discuter du
nom mais si on n'agit pas nous sommes
tous responsables sauf qu'au niveau
comme et haut niveau ça rentre dans la
tête le cac sincèrement moi c'est
indépendant qui rentre dans la tête
mais si on n'agit pas on est tous
responsables de ce que vivent là ça va
on n'avait pas fait un rue cartier sont
fauteurs de troubles
la nation écrit je trouve que l'idée de
cartographier terre de repérer de dire
attention là faut pas stigmatiser les
gens mais vous le ferez pas mais
attention ici il ya eu des cas il faut
agir voilà agissons dans cette rue c'est
très bien ils sont localisés pour lutter
bravo alors ce qui vit boulet vous dit
non vous perdez pas l'idée est bonne
mais pas un quartier c'est toute la
france qui doit être comme ça et puis
marlène bravo parce que c'est toujours
moi j'ai connu marlène moment donc on
sait que jamais de la gay pride de
gallons ensemble il ya longtemps
donc vous allez les diogène et puis ça
devient ça devient vite l'émission tu
crois que c'est des médecins cnom et
steevy boulay l'essai mais il s'est cru
que ça les bajans messia j'étais avec
l'os 4 le combat est très important il
faut lutter contre le harcèlement dream
moi j'ai du mal avec le mot relou déjà
parce que je trouve qu'il n'est pas
digne d'un gouvernement et ensuite
chauve qu'il est inadaptée parce que le
mot relou je trouvais mode pour
l'employeur évidemment choquée les
limites sympathique quand on est
quelqu'un d'assez un relou ça va c'est
une connotation un peu souriante alors
que le harcèlement de rue c'est
extrêmement grave voilà qu'est ce que
vous répondez à sa marine marchande a
tout dit que c'est indigne du
gouvernement rôle ou parce qu'il ya
plein de gens aussi qui ont dit ça sur
wii c'est pas digne du gouvernement
d'aller dans des émissions enfin voila c
voilà c'est vrai je passe morvan je suis
très sensible à ce que vous dites sur le
fait de ne pas minimiser
moi je me suis beaucoup battu contre
l'appellation frotteur en dix ans pas
des fraudeurs ce sont des gens qui
commettent des agressions sexuelles
là l'idée c'était vraiment d'avoir un
truc impactants en politique il ya
beaucoup de sigles et je trouvais c'est
un petit clin d'oeil de dire ben moi je
vais fonder des qsr et les gens sont
très serrés nous avons qu'est ce que
c'est dès qu acer et là des quartiers
sans relou voilà est évidemment steve ya
aussi raison quand il dit qu'il faut que
ce soit tout le territoire
mais l'idée pour nous c'est vraiment
d'avoir un baromètre des zones rouges et
de transformer ces quartiers j'étais
tout à l'heure à châtelet les halles
avec les policiers qui sont en
patrouille
imaginons ce que ça pourrait être
châtelet les halles si on se faisait pas
aborder toutes les trois minutes
en tant qu' en tant que femme que jeune
fille jean messia de quartier son rôle
ou ça vous plaît
écoutez moi j'ai rien j'ai rien contre
je salue le combat de marlène schiappa
pour le
droits des femmes de manière générale
même si je combats votre gouvernement
n'est ce pas mais sur cette question là
je suis très sensible et je salue votre
courage
néanmoins néanmoins je me permets
simplement de vous dire que votre combat
il est efficace que si on arrête de
faire rentrer chaque année viennent de
pays passés par pardonnez moi mais qui
viennent de pays où la femme doit être
couverte soumises ou alors elle est
impudique ou alors passez moi
l'expression c'est une [ __ ]
voilà donc effectivement si vous faites
pas ça on peut pas mettre un flic
derrière chaque femme
vous comprenez alors vous allez me dire
oui mais comment vous le savez c'est moi
je suis je vous fait une consultation de
toutes les femmes à agresser ou pas
verbalement ou physiquement en france
demandez-leur quel est le profil des
personnes et si effectivement je suis à
la maison sur le profil je suis prêt à
m'excuser publiquement mais là le combat
pour les femmes s'il voulait il ne
saurait garder tabou des questions sur
un moment faut ouvrir les yeux
bernard était les problèmes tels qu'ils
sont et non pas quelques et on aimerait
qu'il soit bernard montiel
non monsieur messia ce qui est pratique
avec lui c'est qu'il faut l'enregistrer
une bonne foi pour toi à elle à
ressortir à chaque fois dans le dos ça
vous dérange cette question ça me
dérange pas bonjour je suis d'accord
avec chaque fois qu'on la ramène sur les
plateaux la cette question vous êtes en
train de pousser des vous avez pris de
convulsions qui revient aux coliques ya
pas d relooke 50 ans qu'à tokyo dans le
16è jour etemad melli
antérieure donnée par son département 7
cette question là on me dit toujours une
meilleure estime technique qui n'arrête
de forte et très marrant on a des études
extrêmement sérieuses qui sont capables
de nous démontrer que les arabes et les
noirs en france victimes de
discriminations d'accord que ça veut
dire donc ça veut dire ça veut dire que
lorsque les populations sont des
victimes des statistiques et des gens
mais si la ration sont mises en jambes
et jean messier environ de celle d un
but et le sud vous venez de parler d'un
truc moi j'ai fait un test dans je vous
le dis avec mes équipes on est et on a
essayé de faire louer un appartement un
garçon et on a mis voilà un nom à non
voilà sur l'a8 sur douvres l'arachide
vous dire qu'il n'a pas eu une personne
qui a pris son dossier alors que ce
dossier mettez béton et il n'a pas eu
voilà les mêmes et même l'agent
immobilier qui s'en occupe et nous a dit
c'est et le meilleur dossier mais je ne
sais pas pourquoi ils n'ont pas pris
alors voilà je verrai ça si ça ça c'est
des blasés les choses reprennent grâce à
que ce que cela existe cela ne fait pas
l'ombre d'un doute
maric mais si c'était un vrai phénomène
on devrait assister à des millions de
rachid qui sont dans la rue mais c'est
un fait de guerre quand même la
séparation connaître des phénomènes non
non non les ans est un phénomène et ce
sont des êtres suis pas d'accord avec
vous mais moi je connais plein de gens
et on a fait aussi avec les cv je peux
vous dire avec les cv et vous dire que
c'est exactement le même cas que sur les
appartements où les gens sont très peu
rappelé et il ya une vraie
discrimination
je peux vous dire que je peux vous faire
une étude et vous allez voir que les
chiffres ils sont vraiment prendrait
donc donc ça veut dire que les études
ethniques existe alors puisque vous
faites ces élus là non dans un cas il
existe concernant ces désespérés assure
yalaoui quand ils sont mis l'ambiance et
population les prix n'ont fait sérieux
qui font désormais sur la base du prénom
pour là pour montrer que justement
fonction de votre prénom vous n'êtes pas
traités de la même manière twc vous vous
appeliez marlène ou fatima je l'avais
pas chez nous aux réponses un cv ça il
faut avec moi
ça n'est pas à mon avis un phénomène
parce qu'encore une fois le s'agissant
de la question du logement on a pas on
n'a pas des centaines de milliers
d'étrangers qui dorment dans la rue
j'aimerais les gens ont quand même âge
est vrai qu'on vienne sur le sujet
germaine chaumel sur le sujet les
quartiers on s'enroule ou géraldine
maillet alors quartier son rôle ou
quartiers sont racistes sous des traits
sais que c'est vous êtes très forte
marlène schiappa pour les slogans pour
les acronymes c'est assez branché ces
dynamiques et tout ça relou pour m'a
effectivement je suis un peu comme
guillaume ça une connotation jeunes
c'est à dire que moi j'estime que femme
de 50 ans je suis pas trop dans la cible
alors que je pense qu'une femme de 50
ans avec son temps ouais bah oui non
mais ne peut pas être enfin ne peut pas
être harcelé donc c'est plus pour une
communauté jeunes et après moi je suis
un peu gêné parce qu'en fait les
critères ça veut dire quoi en fait ça
veut dire que bon sifflé non ça va
peut-être pas passé bon allez ça ira
et puis si quelqu'un va vous dire à
madame madame t bones ah non alors là ça
va pas être possible d'ailleurs que je
trouve que la kryte le critère du relou
est quand même assez vagues assez floue
et ensuite on va on va sectorisé alors
on va dire chaque les armes c'est mort
mais la ligne juste après enfin la
station juste après là c'est bien donc
je trouve que c'est pour moi c'est un
peu de la poudre aux yeux mais c'est
très efficace concrètement voilà dix
pour répondre là-dessus derrière
l'appellation évidemment si on faisait
juste on va faire des quartiers sans
relooke tout à fait d'accord avec vous
on dirait vous qu'est ce que c'est que
ce nom mais derrière il ya un vrai
dispositif c'est à dire le baromètre qui
va nous permettre de mesurer le
harcèlement de rue qui va être publiée
sur la base des statistiques du
ministère de l'intérieur et des
remontées des associations chaque année
et derrière pourquoi on veut faire ce
mapping est entre guillemets cette
cartographie c'est vraiment pour ravir
et pour déployer ses forces de sécurité
il ya deux mille policiers qui sont en
civil déployés sur les points rouges de
harcèlement de rue pour les transformer
justement dans ces quartiers sont relou
et comme ces séries tout à l'heure si je
vous avais juste dit en fait on va faire
une cartographie et on va déployer des
forces de l'ordre efficace pour faire
plus de flagrant délit augmenter les
verbalisations m'a peut-être je serais
même pas sur ce plateau
l'appellation je conçois qu'elle puisse
être contestée mais l'idée c'est
vraiment pour une grande visible ce
phénomène de harcèlement de rue et de
push et les actionnaires de deux minutes
alors quartier sans relou est-ce que
voilà est-ce utile de mettre en place
des quartiers sans rôle où il y en a une
qui est pour c'est delphine wespiser tu
ton pas sa dernière
delphine est ce que toi tu as déjà été
victime de rôle ou comme on dit voilà
maintenant ça on appelle ça les relous
maintenant tout le monde va les appeler
les rôles ou à l'eau bien sûr et
géraldine ya une différence quand tu
parles avec quelqu'un et puis un échange
ou alors quand tu te balades dans la rue
tu ne demande rien à personne et a deux
possibilités soit tu baisse les yeux
parce que si tu croises le regard il va
y avoir une phrase ou quoi soit tu le
regardes est bon il va quand même y
avoir une phrase on est hyper
progressiste alors en 2021
enfin progressons sur ce sujet et bravo
pour votre initiative parce que moi j'ai
plus envie qu'on me dise mademoiselle t
charmante ça me saoule c'est pas un
compliment c'est pas un compliment moi
quand je marche dans la rue dont c'est
pas de toute façon quand il ya une
personne soit elle ce elles se sont
hyper forte moissonner charmante et
bernard quand tu me dis je suis
charmante c'est différent tu vois rien
qui doit rue du trône et 8 heures on
fait ça je ne connais ambages et ont
envie qu'ils fassent une appréciation
sur mon physique d'autant plus en été
quand même être un mini short alors là
ça fuse non on n'a pas envie et quand
ils sont en groupe c'est encore pire
donc au bout d'un moment avançons sur
les sujets que la justice soutiennent
tout ça madame la ministre justement à
la position initiale est ce que est ce
que vous voyez à une une coïncidence
entre les quartiers séparatistes et les
autres sans relou est-ce qu il ya une
super position possible
est ce qu'il ya une forme de séparatisme
dans ces quartiers sans relou est ce que
est ce que les gens qui agissent comme
ça sont plus fréquemment présent dans
les quartiers séparatistes parce que en
fait si vous faites pas cet exercice là
pardonnez moi mais c'est la poésie la
tartiflette quoi moi je vais vous dire
que pour la politique la tartiflette
c'est à dire on n'y voit rien sa dalle
peu de hellange et on n'y voit rien et
donc du coup la panique et pas efficace
accord merci oui allez-y juste deux
exemples basé sur mon expérience
personnelle parce que hélas on a tout
des histoires comme ça qui nous sont
restés en mémoire moi j'ai grandi dans
une cité sur le bord du périphérique et
avec ma soeur très clairement on devait
fomenter des stratégies d'évitement
avant de sortir ont regardé par la
fenêtre ou disait bail à la bande qui
est là là il ya un type qui est là donc
là on fait comme si on n'entendait pas
là on avance était jamais vous professez
densité mais je vais vous raconter une
autre chose qui m'est arrivé quand
j'étais pas la mère de famille j'étais
trentenaire j'étais suivie dans un train
par un type qui était bien sous tous
rapports à la gare montparnasse qui
étaient en costume-cravate avec une
petite mallette et un gobelet starbucks
et la peur de ma vie j'en suis sorti je
sais pas comment mais qui m'a fait de
façon très agressive et donc je crois
qu'avoir un costard et habiter dans le
xvième c'est pas ça garantit pas que
d'accord et j'ai plein de cadeaux j'ai
plein d'exemples comme celui qui lie à
débloquer marlène schiappa je vous le
dis par les mecs en costume avec je vous
le dis question benjamin ouest qui en
fait qui met en jeu la phrase c'est le
mot quartier j'ai peur qu'on me lance
alors le combat évidemment il est noble
n'y a pas de débat là dessus il faut
effectivement douter surtout ce qui est
fort d'harcèlement mais le fait de
l'hérault quartier donc on va montrer du
doigt une zone en dix ans dans cette
zone il ya pas mal de jeu il ya pas mal
de gens qui sont harceleur donc les à
moi je suis bien que je vive dans dans
ce quartier je me trouve à simuler un
endroit et j'ai peur que ça fragmente
encore plus les lévy encore encore plus
les quartiers qu'on dise encore plus
avoir dans cette zone là bas déjà que
c'était le bordel et en plus il son
harceleur et là j'ai peur que ça vous
montrent du doigt
voilà et c'est ce qui c'est ce qui mine
en boîte dans cette formulation joie
exactement ce que voulait dire parce
qu'on a eu exactement ce débat ce matin
avec les élections de la police la
gendarmerie et la préfecture de paris
et on se disait est ce qu'on doit rendre
public ce mapping
ou est-ce que ce mapping il doit être un
outil d'action a pour les forces de
l'ordre pour déployer justement les
forces de l'ordre dans ces quartiers
est-ce qu'on peut rendre public c'est le
baromètre qui lui calculé phénomènes de
harcèlement de rue en justice qu'il a
perdue vous dit non vous saviez vous
plaît pas ça alors moi ça me plaît pas
du tout parce qu'en fait j'ai apprennent
de dans ma tête de priorité on vient de
recevoir le papa d'anne-lise vous avez
un monsieur donc est sorti le 4 mai et
il a agressé le 24 octobre
ça veut dire que entre temps on a eu
aucune traçabilité donc qu'est-ce qui va
pas quand même une priorité à s'attaquer
par exemple à être des délinquants
sexuels et faire des cartographies par
exemple de délinquants sexuels pour
qu'on sache où ils se trouvent
avant de s'attaquer aux rôles ou c'est
juste moi un président de jury et
différents n'ont pas annoncé jeudi j'ai
que je me pose des questions je pense
pas que ce soit la priorité du moment
il vient d'avoir l'exemple sur le
plateau
alors moi honnêtement moi vont pour la
bonne volonté et toutes les initiatives
sont bonnes à prendre et vous entends tu
es beaucoup donc très bien en revanche
une réserve mais aussi ce relou et
quartier parce que pardonnez moi on en
papa ou des mouches
parce que les ce que vous appelez les
relous c'est le fait de deux la
politique hôtel et rocker et maman il
laisserait les hommes s'ils fm le léguer
qui entrent dans cette catégorie
et puis ensuite par donnez-moi vôtre
semble appeler ça la police de proximité
et les grands frères il faisait
exactement ce que vous voulez faire
alors pourquoi on rétablit pas tout
bêtement la police de proximité en
élimine la notion de quartier de relou
et ils sont présents l'aï veille alors
plusieurs questions différentes
alors oui le miz inter germain a déployé
justement un certain nombre de forces de
l'ordre supplémentaires dix milles
jusqu'à la fin du quinquennat d'
emmanuel macron pour justement avoir
cette présence forte mais là il s'agit
pas de grands freins il s'agit vraiment
de gens qui vont venir verbaliser et
ensuite pour répondre à la question qui
était posée sur le l'ordre de priorité
d'abord moi j'ai vu le témoignage du
papa est évidemment je suis absolument
révolté comme vous tous j'imagine par ce
qui s'est passé et s'adresse bien sûr
mon soutien à sa fille et à toutes les
personnes qui ont été victimes de
violences sexistes ou sexuelles mais
évidemment ce sont il ya un continuum
des violences sexistes et sexuelles ça
commence par des phénomènes de
harcèlement de rue en suisse et à l'état
agression sexuelle y aller violent et
c'est une espèce de sentiment d'impunité
généralisée qui amène certains hommes à
se sentir autorisé finalement commettre
des violences sexuelles en faisant de
toute façon je ne serai pas sanctionné
donc il ya une vraie révolution de la
justice a mené où on y est vraiment on
s'y attelle avec le garde des sceaux
pour faire en sorte qu'ils aient des
peines exemplaires que les suisses ne
sortent pas de prison qui a des
préventions de la récidive
c'est vraiment un changement culture de
long terme très fort à la fois là c'est
vite là dessus on va voir ce qu'en
pensent les téléspectateurs oui 37% non
à 63% donc il va falloir voilà c'est ici
un premier sondage
voilà marine le pen aussi elle a
commencé voilà apparaît aujourd'hui
malheureusement à les autres